وقال منسق والاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيرربي في
هذه الاثناء النواشنه تحث الطرفين
العسكريين في السودان على التمسك بوقف
اطلاق النار وتمديده واشار الى ان
الولايات المتحده تريد ان يتوقف العنف
تماما وهي تواصل العمل مع الطرفين لتمديد
وقف اطلاق النار مشيرا الى ان الشعب
السوداني يريد الانتقال الى حكومه مدنيه
واوضح كيربيان الولايات المتحده اوقفت
عملياتها في السفاره في الخرطوم لكنها لم
تفك علاقاتها الدبلوماسيه مع السودان وان
السفيره سيواصل عمله من الخارج موضحا ان
خطوط الاتصال مع الطرفين ستظل مفتوحه وقال
كيربي ان واشنطن قلقه من التقارير التي
تتحدث عن نقص الغذاء والماء والدواء
والمعدات الطبيه في السودان واضاف ان
الجهود مستمره لمساعده الامريكيين وتسهيل
اجلاء من قالوا انهم يرغبون بالمغادره
واكد كيربي مقتل امريكي ثاني في السودان